did you ever wonder what would happen if
Gabby didn't shoot Aaron or what if this
guy ate Aaron and inherited his Titan
powers or even better could the
real-life modern military stop the
rumbling well I spent a long time
researching these topics and here's
exactly what would happen did it ever
seem weird to you that Aaron's founding
Titan looks like this it's literally
just a bunch of Bones and looks nothing
similar to the previous founding Titans
in the series well what if I tell you
that the one responsible for this was
none other than Gabby although she
didn't kill Aaron when she shot him she
managed to split his body and head and
later when Aaron transformed you can
clearly see here that the bones grew out
from his head this means that if Gabby
didn't shoot him before he touched Zeke
it's most likely that his entire body
would transform and his Titan form would
look completely different judging by the
other founding Titan users throughout
the series his appearance would probably
look similar to his attack Titan form
with bones protruding from his body
similar to Amir he would also be much
bigger I did some research online and it
seems that Aaron's current form is at
minimum around 600 meters in length this
means that if he wasn't shot and his
full body was transformed normally he
would be at least 10 times bigger than
the wall Titans another interesting
thing is that in this scenario Aaron
would be able to defend himself against
other Titan Shifters and warriors
instead of just walking around okay this
all sounds pretty cool but what would
happen after he transforms well there
are actually many things that would play
out differently this time around for
starters the alliance couldn't land on
top of Aaron as he would now walk
normally on two legs also armin's plan
to transform and Destroy Aaron with an
explosion would also not work now as
Aaron could easily Harden his body to
avoid any damage to be honest I just
don't see how this version of Aaron
could ever be defeated he would be way
overpowered the only thing the alliance
could do is land on Aaron's shoulders
and try to break into his nape and pull
out his human form but let's be honest
with ourselves the chances of them
pulling off something like this no pun
intended are really Slim and the only
way they could win is if Aaron lets them
meaning if Aaron wants to continue the
rumbling he could easily destroy the
entire world and there would be no one
capable of stopping him man I guess we
should be thinking Gabby for shooting
him after after all there are still
three scenarios left to cover and the
last one will blow your mind okay did
you ever wonder if the modern real world
military could stop the rumbling in the
show the combined military of the entire
world was completely helpless against
the army of wall Titans they tried
shooting them from the water with ships
from the land with artillery and even
tried throwing bombs on them from Planes
however even after all that they've only
managed to kill a few Titans judging by
the weapons and the technology in the
attack on Titan world we can safely say
that they probably live somewhere
between the 1910s and the 1920s since
then technology has evolved greatly and
we now have much stronger weapons than
ever before so if the rumbling was to
happen in the real world would we be
able to defend ourselves according to
fans calculations there should be
roughly 500 000 colossal Titans in the
rumbling to put this into perspective
let's take one of the largest armies in
the world the US Army it currently has
around 1 million active members so just
imagine half of the US Army is 60 meters
tall all colossal Titans okay now that
you understand just how big the rumbling
is let's see if the world could do
anything to stop it the first important
thing is that colossal Titans are pretty
fast and it was stated they move around
65 kilometers per hour this means that
the Army's stationary artillery weapons
would be pretty much useless as the
rumbling would catch up within minutes
and completely destroy them a similar
thing would also happen with ships which
would also be crushed pretty quickly as
they have nowhere to escape now although
everything so far would happen pretty
much the same as in the anime I believe
the Army would be able to kill much more
Titans than Marley did however even if
by some miracle they managed to kill
let's say 50 000 Titans it's still
pretty much nothing compared to their
numbers so does that mean that even the
modern Army has no chance against the
Titans well not exactly as the modern
artery has something they didn't have a
hundred years ago nukes okay so just
throw a few nukes and that's it right
not really you see judging by the
information I could find the average
blast radius of a nuclear bomb is around
10 kilometers which means that if the
Army wanted to cover the entire rumbling
with nukes they would probably need more
than 500 nuclear bombs that would
obviously be impossible since it would
wipe out the entirety of humanity
however if you think about it the world
doesn't really have to kill every single
Titan to survive remember chapter 137 as
soon as Levi killed Zeke the entire
rumbling stopped you probably see where
I'm going with this if the Army can
throw just one bomb right on Aaron's
founding Titan it should be enough to
immediately stop the rumbling I know
this is kind of anticlimactic but
considering how the rumbling is
activated through Aaron and Zeke this
plan should work so if you ever have a
dream like this don't worry you should
be safe probably before we explain what
would happen if Aaron inherited the
Colossal Titan instead of Armin let's
first explain what would happen if this
pure Titan ate Aaron properly and
inherited his Titan Powers although the
main character dying so early in the
show seems really bad there are actually
some really interesting things that
would happen in this scenario okay
firstly who even is this guy some of you
may think that he is just a random Titan
but that's not really true you see he
was actually one of the main members of
LDN restorationists back in Marley you
can clearly see him in this picture okay
now that we know who he is how will the
story progress from there after eating
Aaron he would turn back into his human
form and from there it's most likely
that the corps would imprison him
underground and try to question him and
here comes the first major change since
this guy is the LDN restorationist he
would tell the core everything about
Marley and the outside world just
imagine them learning all of this in
episode 5 it would be game changing this
also means they would have no reason to
go to shigashina as all secrets would
already be revealed another thing they
would realize is that both colossal and
armored Titans must be humans and that
they are probably living among them
royal family would be really scared by
this development as everyone now knows
about them so it's likely they would
just keep hiding and observing the
situation now that the survey corps
knows that they live on the island and
that there is a limited amount of Titans
outside they will probably go out and
slowly kill Titans one by one similar to
how they did during the time skip since
the core never attempted to go to
shigashina that also means that they
never fought Annie meaning that all
three Warriors would still be Undercover
on the island eventually after some time
Peak and Zeke would arrive and start
transforming people into Titans same as
in the original story everyone including
the new attack Titan would go out there
and try to stop them with Zeke's
appearance it's finally time for
warriors to act and together with Zeke
and Peak they should be able to defeat
the new attack Titan and the survey
corps pretty easily another thing
that'll make the scouts defeat certain
is Amir who will make a deal with Marley
in order to save Historia this would
literally mean that six Titans would
attack the core at the same time and no
matter how good Aaron is at strategizing
they would stand absolutely no chance
against them in the end the Warriors
would return to Marley Victorious and
both the attack and jaw Titans would be
passed onto the new holders Marley would
soon launch another attack on the island
completely destroying the remnants of
the walls I'm glad this dude didn't eat
Aaron properly this would be a disaster
and finally the moment you've all been
waiting for what would happen if Irwin
inherited Colossal Titan instead of
Armin and let me tell you there are some
insane things that would happen in this
version firstly Aaron would make it to
the basement and realize his father was
right about everything on the other hand
Aaron would be even more mad and
depressed than before as not only did he
learn that there are people outside of
the walls but one of his best friends is
also dead his hatred toward Marley and
the outside world would grow even
further than before and he would want to
take revenge as soon as possible after
some time had passed the survey corps
would clean the island of Titans and
start planning their attack on Marley
everything would play out pretty much
the same from here with Aaron going
rogue and attacking on his own with the
survey corps supporting him however the
main difference here is that Aaron is
much tougher than Armin and is prepared
to do whatever is necessary after
blowing up the port the commander would
start walking towards Aaron in order to
help him in his battle against other
warriors with both Aaron and Erwin now
fighting the battle would be much easier
and they would manage to defeat all the
Warriors and instead of just leaving
Erin wouldn't waste this opportunity to
try and steal their powers as it would
make it impossible for Marley to launch
any sort of counter-attack with this the
raid is a complete success Aaron and
Erwin ate all Warriors Zeke excited with
them and even Sasha survived although
Paradise Island now has all Titans
Powers their safety still is a guarantee
the outside world is more terrified of
albions than ever before and if nothing
is done about them they will surely
retaliate at some point knowing Aaron's
personality and how much he wants to
keep his friends safe he would see the
rumbling as the only option for
permanent peace therefore as in the
original he would trick Zeke and gain
the founders power thousands of colossal
Titans will start marching toward other
nations and this time there will be no
one willing to stop them Armin and the
Warriors are dead in this version so the
only person capable of stopping Aaron
would be Erwin but Woody well if we
reflect on Erwin's character throughout
the series I think it's really unlikely
he would try to stop Aaron he is not as
naive as some of the other Corps members
and even though he wouldn't like Aaron's
plan and consider it extreme he would
let it happen so in this scenario Aaron
would completely destroy the entire
world leaving no one outside the walls
alive to keep the PC created Aaron would
eradicate the Titan powers from the
world so history never repeats itself
again click on this video where we
explained 40 secret things you didn't
know about Aaron Yeager